now
mourning a life lost too soon and in a
terrible way the killing of a
four-year-old boy is taking center stage
tonight good evening and thanks for
joining us here at six i'm denise valdez
and i'm brian loftis the family of the
four-year-old boy telling eight news now
his name is mason dominguez police tell
us the boy's body was found in a freezer
yesterday inside a home near the
intersection of lamb boulevard and kerry
avenue
now this is the man accused of that
crime brandon tosland he was in court
earlier on today he is facing open
murder charges in this case the victim
is one of his girlfriend's children
and there's a lot more to get to here we
do have team coverage tonight with
details you will only see right here on
8 news now first we're going to send it
over to david charns he has the latest
on the investigation david
brian denise the house where detectives
say this four-year-old's body was found
is dark tonight there is a truck parked
out front
investigators tell me in that truck
they found sand and debris from this
home's backyard now more on that in a
moment
first here's what we know about the
investigation into this child's burden
found in a freezer in a trash bag that's
how investigators say they discovered
four-year-old mason dominguez's body
inside this northeast valley home
we obviously have a report from auburn
35 year old brandon tozlund accused of
killing the boy in concealing his body
for at least two months he looked down
as prosecutors read aloud the details of
his girlfriend's son's death the
four-year-old victim in this particular
case was found deceased court documents
say toslin told the boy's mother that he
had found mason unconscious in december
they say the boy's body had visible
injuries but it's too soon to say just
how he died they say toslin told his
girlfriend mason was sick and that she
wasn't allowed to see the child we do
know from our interviews that the
suspect
is alleged to have been physical with
the victim and had spanked him
excessively on more than one occasion on
tuesday mason's sister handed a note to
a teacher saying she and her mother were
being held against their will court
documents alleging toslin tied up
mason's mother even handcuffing her when
they drove in a car
that eventually led to the discovery
tuesday of mason's body in the garage we
observed a very large hole inside the
backyard that appears to be that someone
was digging a grave
that hole is at least eight feet deep
and my colleague joe moeller will have
more on that part of this investigation
in just a moment tozland is due in court
again on monday
in terms of how mason died that remains
a big question tonight and one
investigators don't have the answer to
they say that will take several days
live near
carrion lamb tonight i'm david charns
live local now
david thank you for that now let's get
right over to joel moller he does
continue our team coverage he has been
talking to the family of the victim and
joe what do you know tonight
brian and denise we're on the sidewalk
here on lamb on the other side of this
wall right here is that eight foot deep
hole and metro police are now
investigating as a possible grave we
have a look at it from a neighbor's home
from the second story of that home
meanwhile the family of the victim's
father are now reacting to what happened
it is a chilling sight from a neighbor's
second story window you can see this big
hole police say they are investigating
as a possible grave neighbors tell me it
appeared a month and a half ago
basically overnight as the investigation
continues into the death of mason
dominguez his father's side of the
family is left heartbroken he was the
one that was going to carry on my
brother's
last name mason's father elijah
dominguez passed away from pneumonia in
january of 2021. we spoke to elijah's
sister shirona ruiz villalobos as she
was traveling from california she
described her nephew mason he was just
so full of joy like he was just as soon
as he was born he was just like the
light of all of our life it's just super
unfortunate that
he's wrong a little over a month after
elijah died she says mason's mother
dacia maldonado moved in with tozland at
this home i reached out multiple times
via text to
dossier and email just concerning the
whereabouts of my niece and nephew she
says the family knew toaslan before
elijah passed away but never thought
this could happen
questions linger especially about the
possible grave ruiz villalobo says she
wants to know about what was happening
inside this home and why little mason
was missing for so long i don't think
she's innocent how do you not know where
your child
[Music]
is now back out here live she also tells
me they set up a gofundme to get mason
buried by his father we have a link to
that up on our website eightnewsnow.com
reporting live joe mulder live local now
and don't forget there is help for
anyone who might be experiencing
domestic abuse local non-profit safe
nest offers a 24-hour confidential
hotline that you can call you can text
the phone number is on your screen at
702-646-4981
by the way the organization also
provides shelter and counseling